Chúng tôi không thể hảm ơn sọ tháng chín dở như nhau,
thôi đồng bảo an để thật quốc hậm bảo việu về dự tháng việu quên,
ra hảm sọ tháng lối với kế hoạt thành động chung tròan dịt gcp0x,
năm hành gibert mấy lâm về chương trình hành nhân quyết run,
cũng như nghệ quên thay hai bà mô sắc lập thảo thận này.
Dự thả vẫn bạn, gió Trung Quốc và ngà để sất nhằm đối trọng với quy định của nhóm EBA,
gồm cả nước pháp, đứt, anh về kích hoạt cơ trẻ tại hảm đặt rất là trường phát mối hấp quốc,
đối với Iran vô lực dự mỏ thèo dí cp0x, hảm hí quên hai bà mô sắc lập thơ trẻ,
đáp vãi bóng phíao thận của Anzari Trung Quốc và kích tan và ngà,
chín phíao trọng và hảm đủ quyết dân bảo an đặt không thung qua ra hảm dí cp0x,
hảm hí quên hai bà mô tương này đồng ý với biểu phói đồng bảo an lên của bác mỏ,
lực của Trung Quốc và ngà nhằm kéo ra hảm đặt trường phát cho Iran thèo dí cp0x.
Hảm chức, mô mẹ bà đã kích hoạt cơ trẻ sắp bác,
mò lệnh Trung Phát Iran tự đồng băng theo thật gcp0x sẽ tự đặc đực tà dáb đặt từ ngày hảm đặt thẳng chiến.